I think a lot of
companies are seeing
the importance and the value
of hosting retreats now
especially after two
years of Covid where
there was a growing
sense of isolation.
A lot of companies that either
gave up their office during Covid
and moved to a fully
remote model
or a hybrid model have
reached out to us
and asked if we could help
them plan their first retreat.
You see their names on Slack
or they pop up in your
email all the time,
but being able to put that face
to the name and allowing you
to actually develop
that relationship.
We’ve just anecdotally
seen people write in
after on the post-trip surveys
talking about how reinvigorated
and re-energized
they feel after the retreat,
having been able
to kind of reconnect
with their colleagues.
The tools and our ability to work
remotely has made it possible
to build what we’ve built.
But the human connection
piece of it is vital
to what we do and the retreats
just amplify that a million fold
every time we do them.
For us, these retreats
have become
probably our number one retention tool because
people grow closer together,
they understand each other more,
they end up working better together because of it.
And the excitement
level goes through the roof
and it has this halo
effect that lasts
for the rest of the year
if we do them right.
My advice is if they’re done right
and you go in with
the right attitude
and you actually really care
about them, the return is
absolutely no brainer.
Somebody will find us either
through a referral and get
connected to us directly or they just find us on the internet
and we’ll have a conversation
talking a little bit about what it is that they’re looking to do,
whether it be a short
celebration-type retreat,
or if it’s going to be
like a few days
abroad where there’s a mix
of work and some fun.
From there, we will put
together a proposal
sharing 3 to 5 destinations,
talking about where
we think would be
an appropriate place to take
the group based on budget,
where people are coming from,
what they’re trying to accomplish.
From there, once we lock it in,
we start to put together
the day by day itinerary and
the corresponding budget.
And then as we get
closer to the date,
we’re working on the little things
like what are we going to see?
What are we going to taste?
What are we going to feel?
I get a call from Sean
or either clients.
What kind of needs you have? Tell me the age.
What kind of expectations?
If it’s in Florence,
we think about something.
If it’s in Rome, we think
about something else.
Step by step, we go
through the program,
even though if it’s a simple day,
you know, we need really, really
a lot of planning and
scheduled times.
Let’s say, maybe for this,
I would need this castle.
So I call the castle and I explain the things that I need.
And then I call
the cooking classes
and I call the mama and say,
“Listen, we need to
do this and do this,
and it has to be done
for this reason.”
If you’ve got a group that’s coming from all over the globe,
what we recommend is
a four-night length.
We just find that that first night,
people can be a little bit jet lagged.
Keep it simple.
Make sure everybody feels warmly welcomed
and then a dinner,
but nothing too serious.
The next few days, it gives
you enough time
to really allocate
a fair amount of the agenda
towards mixing in the work
and then also having
enough free time
or optional activities sprinkled in.
Typically, the best model is to do
the work in the morning,
so you have your breakfast
and then everybody
kind of gathers in
the meeting space.
You might have a breakout session where you just
get together with your smaller team or department.
Ideally, you’re trying to end
the day by about 2:00 PM.
It gives your people enough
time to either relax,
have some leisure time
to go explore the property
or potentially go off-site.
Or you can host full-team
team building
or an optional activity where
the group can get together
and actually just have
some fun together.
We work together on the theme.
We’ll lean into that
and create games
and contests and other events
along the way to tie into
that and really make it
feel like a cohesive
over-the-top experience.
The biggest thing is to deliver
happiness, joy and emotion.
So no matter what the activity is
it can be a simple wine tasting, can be a cooking class,
or maybe a sort of game with
the cars like we did with Sean.
There’s this company Plex that we’ve worked with for many years.
One of my favorite activities
that we planned, we took them
to Tuscany back in 2016.
They were looking for something
to get people out
exploring the region.
We staged essentially
‘The Italian Job,’ a bank heist.
So we told the group to come
meet us in the parking lot.
And sure enough,
their version of the special police
comes tearing down the driveway, sirens blazing,
and he pulls to a stop in front
of them and he gets out
and everybody’s looking at each other, having no idea what’s going on.
And he basically starts to
explain that there’s been
a robbery in the nearby town
of Monte San Savino
and their police force is small
and they heard that this group was in town and hopefully
they could help enlist them
to solve this crime.
They drive to Monte San Savino
and we had an actor
with his wrists
bound and tape over his mouth
sitting in front of this bank.
These attendees walk up,
they take the tape off
and he says, “Yes, yes,
I was just robbed.
There were three people
who just left this bank
and as they were leaving,
this piece of paper
dropped out of
their back pocket.”
And it just kind of evolved
into this really fun circuit
with a whole bunch of
diversions and side quests.
It was just an awesome way
to explore the destination
that we were in,
but at the same time bring
the team together.
I definitely think that the industry around retreats and offsites
is just at the cusp of exploding.
Over the course of the last
two years, obviously with Covid
tons of companies moved
into a remote structure
or at least a hybrid structure.
It’s allowed companies to hire
the best talent wherever they are.
Being apart or being isolated
and working from home
for the last two years
has really reinforced
this idea that there just
is something intangible
about getting together in person,
what you just can’t
replace by Zoom calls
or Zoom games and
meetings on Slack.
What we’ll see, at least for the next few years is companies
probably will try to keep
them close to home
as they navigate
their first retreats.
But over the course of
the next few years,
I do think that we’ll start to see
a trend of companies going further abroad
and not going to
the usual places.
Europe has always been a very popular destination with our clients,
but what we’re excited about is
companies are starting to ask
us a little bit more about off
the beaten path destinations.